hey what is up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
it's been a long time coming waiting for
the next Nexus why am I even talking
about that well this is the LG g2 aka
the almost Nexus let me explain
let's go back a second to the Nexus 4
when I first saw it I said my review
that this is the perfect combination
between the previous Nexus the Galaxy
Nexus and LG's current flagship at that
time which was the lg optimus G and
that's naturally what happens when
Google picks LG for the hardware partner
for the Nexus LG adapts something that
they're already making into something
that works with what Google wants so in
terms of design a lot of that nexuses
points came from the current LG flagship
at that time the Optimus G now flash
forward to 2013 where the next Nexus is
right around the corner the hardware
partner for Nexus is still LG and this
is LG's current flagship the LG g2 so
you can think of this as the sort of
almost Nexus a peek into what we'll
probably see running stock Android 4.4
KitKat in a couple of weeks on a Google
event stage and you can also see in this
device what LG thinks it takes to take
down the Galaxy s4 as the most popular
Android phone right now and as it turns
out a lot of that involves copying what
Samsung did with the Galaxy s4 first of
all though there's no way around it this
phone is an absolute beast on paper a
lot of people don't realize it but this
phone flat-out wins the spec war right
now if that's what you're into is a
mighty Snapdragon 800 chip inside a 2
gigabytes of RAM 3000 milliamp hour
battery in the United States a 5.2 inch
1080p edge-to-edge display and a 13
megapixel optically stabilized camera in
other words it's a beast I know we say
specs don't matter that much but it's
kind of hard to deny that a device with
these types of internals is going to
perform well but we'll get to that in a
second what's really unique though about
this LG g2 is the actual design of the
device and the button layout you may
have noticed that there are no buttons
on the top or on the right hand side or
on the left-hand side or on the bottom
of the device all of the buttons on the
lg g2 are on the back so it's
interesting choice it really keeps the
phone feeling sleek and clean and after
a few quick days of actually using it
this
I got used to it pretty quickly which
may seem weird but what's nice is when
you're holding the phone your hands tend
to fall nicely in line with those
buttons on the back even if you don't
have massive hands like me I know I have
big hands but I've let other people try
it and the first reaction is usually
well at least my fingers are right where
I hold it they land right on the buttons
everything else about the design though
is still similar to the Galaxy s4 that
it's aiming at they have a similar
footprint similar shape similar
curvature and even very similar
materials though the g2 adds this metal
band all the way around all the edges of
the phone in an effort to feel I guess a
bit more premium and both devices also
have a removable back coated with that
super glossy plastic that I'm personally
not really a fan of we can always add a
case or a decal to the back like I did
with my s4 later but the g2 manages to
have a slightly larger 5.2 inch HD IPS
display with it's much thinner bezels
and on-screen buttons instead of
Samsung's physical ones and this display
by itself is excellent for a smartphone
brilliant brightness so it's viewable
just about anywhere plus a super high
pixel density very good color
reproduction for an IPS display and good
scratch resistant glass on top of
everything literally like a boss anyway
there are some other minor things about
this hardware like the downward facing
speaker which is pretty good and kind of
loud but also kinda tinny and fires
audio sideways when the device is in
landscape mode and there's also this
hilariously long TV antenna on the
Korean version to get better reception
for the preinstalled TV watching apps or
you can use it to freak people out in
the street if you want to convince
people you have an insanely weird
looking phone from the 80s or something
but let's get back to those buttons for
a sec when the display is off you can
actually hold down those back buttons
you can use the volume up button to
quickly open LG's Notes app or the
volume down button as a shortcut to open
the camera which is a nice touch and
speaking of the camera it's a strong
point on this device which gives me a
glimmer of hope for a great camera on
the next Nexus the camera on the lg g2
here is fantastic like it takes great
pictures and video and it's thanks to
that sensor the glass and the optical
image stabilization so the software
thanks to LG's skin is a little bit ugly
and I'm not a fan of the viewfinder at
all
but you can see exactly what they tried
to do here it's almost as if they said
to their software engineers hey you see
that Samsung Galaxy s4 camera feature
your job is to build that into our
camera
boom it's in they have dual shot they
have the photosphere mode everything is
here it's like Samsung added everything
but the kitchen sink at the end of the
day the photos it takes are really quite
good they're top-notch
I'd say the camera here is top three
Android smartphone cameras I've ever
used although that may of course change
very soon but yeah I've been impressed
with the photos it takes in any kind of
light indoors or outdoors and it opens
the camera and takes all these photos
very quickly thanks to that software
shortcut and the well immense power of
the Snapdragon 800 so that's what
matters to a lot of people and it's
going to get these shots really quickly
and taken in great quality so the long
story short here is that from my
experience this is a potentially
incredible device ruined by awful LG
software but yet gives me hope for the
future at the same time because if the
next Nexus physically looks anything
like this I'm going to be a very happy
person but all the biggest downsides for
this device come from that LG skin on
the top of Android it's Android 4.2 with
this incredibly large LG UI on top of it
that I happen to think looks quite ugly
inconsistent even a little bit tacky or
Goudy I mean there's unnecessary
animations all over the place
distracting delays in the amount of time
it takes for things to happen or to do
things changes just for the sake of
changes and overall just a ton of things
that need to be cleaned up and that's
just a simple way of putting it I mean
the first time I pull down the
notification draw I think my jaw was on
the floor at how bad it looked really I
think they can do a lot better in this
department but what's crazy is the
biggest Pro is the Snapdragon 800
doesn't even break a sweat
this phone is consistently fast and it
seems like the skin doesn't weigh it
down at all maybe the skin isn't really
all that heavy after all or maybe the
Snapdragon 800 is just that much of a
beast but it lasted all day with this
crazy power - thanks to the 3000
milliamp hour battery so even if you are
lost in the software and it takes you
forever to do what you want to do
because of all the animations or changes
you can still rest assured that it'll
keep doing exactly what it's doing all
day at lightning speed thanks to that
chip that's for sure this phone is a
Reimer but if i was to consider using
the g2 full-time I would really wish it
was a lot lighter a lot cleaner and I
mean ultimately a lot closer to stock
Android like a Nexus so at the end of
the day the lg g2
really is quite an interesting device
obviously the biggest difference between
it and just about any other device out
there is the buttons on the back and
when people first see this for the first
time you're going to think it's insane
why would anyone have buttons on the
back of their phone that just doesn't
make sense
on day 1 and day 2 of owning the phone
you might still think that but on day 3
4 & 5 you start to get to know where the
buttons are on day 6 7 8 9 10 you really
start to get used to it and I've been
using this one for a bit now and I don't
even look at the buttons anymore and I'm
totally used to having them on the back
of the phone so that's pretty cool but
either way the next Nexus won't have
those buttons like we've said but
ideally this is probably the body of the
next Nexus what we're looking at right
here anyway thank you for watching this
has been a quick LG g2 full review if
you were to give a thumbs up below if
you enjoyed it very much more coming up
soon especially this weekend next thank
you for watching and I'll talk to you
guys in the next one peace